okay hmm four people joining this
livestream we are talking about some
somewhat sophisticated features of the
neuron that framework of language so
there is a thing called net map operator
which I already don't remember exactly
what it does so let's go look at its
documentation um so this is part of
functional construction of neural nets
and mapped over sequence of inputs to
give a sequence of outputs okay so
there's a linear layer I have to say
that I've never been thrilled with this
input arrow to UM I mean it's always
struck me is I mean what does that that
means what why do you need the input
arrow there it's a shape specification
for for the different ports so typically
I mean the ports can be named anything
but typically but but why isn't it
defaulting to the input port I just say
summation layer of two anyway that
that's a minor issue let's not deal with
that right now okay so let's just try to
understand what this is doing so threads
across a batch of sequences of different
lengths so if I put
okay I apply the sequence to a sequence
of vectors
okay okay so this threads okay so if I
it were to put in another thing here I
don't quite understand so if I were to
put in a um that's already a batch so
like this
yeah okay so that takes the okay I get
it
um okay so now what is the proposal so
their various limitations of this this
map operator and we relaxing many of
them simultaneously because it's
economical implementation wise to do it
the cool things are to have more than
one input and output for the internet
I'm just going to be horrifically
complicated isn't it I don't honestly
don't think so okay well let's look at
roughly what you're proposing yeah it's
good to look at the examples but I think
it's also good to contextualize what
these generalizations are conceptually
you could you can think of what this
thing is doing what mapping is in
general not just for neural networks as
a function it's kind of a little bit
like a creature like a little insect and
it's walking across the input array or
input arrays what is it doing is that
excreting things it's it's like a spider
that's producing a thread of silk no
never mind exactly yeah
so the different inputs are different
legs that it has right if there's only
one input which is the normal case with
map of course then it's it's like
hopping it's got one leg right I think
women I think the spider is losing it
but anyway go ahead so are you proposing
I mean with respect to ordinary map okay
the you know obviously ordinary map has
some just takes one argument forms are
you proposing something where there's a
multi argument form there essentially
yes that is there is a connection to map
thread which is the multi argument form
but it's more general than that it turns
out
turns out that our language doesn't
actually support the most general thing
you could do let's forget the neuron
that case what what are we talking about
here
so I do connect to that right so
connections to existing functions you
see that section there yeah so more legs
is like having more inputs that's map
thread yeah
there's no analogy for having more
outputs that's kind of good a lot
actually there is with the new subset
map tell me about that I don't know but
what I show you hopefully it in here so
subset map see if you can guess what it
is from its name and other things let me
show you subset map mm-hmm
oh don't tell me it doesn't do that
I must maybe it's in a prototype build
yes and there is a documentation page
for them at least in a few joist one
alright so let's see if subset map
yes subset map is in there okay so let
me show you
subject map so let's say
then let's say range of 10 and then
let's say 6 8 actually I don't need the
double bracket so just need one level
brackets
okay II understand what it did
yeah okay so what this is doing is this
is a two argument to output function so
for example let's imagine you were doing
a sorting Network this would immediately
let you do a sorting Network you just
give the the elements you know the
interchanges to be made there it makes
sense you know I have to say one thing
I'm wondering why do we not have a
subset fold list a subset fold
what can I ask quickly I can say this
say again yeah those are the positions
that's a span is it not no it doesn't
intend to be a span I could I could say
it's not a span at all that those are
just part numbers okay he chose an
ambiguous example then could you try six
nine
okay yeah the seven and eight remain
unchanged exactly right and I could I
could make this clearer by saying you
know if I put in there you know let's
say actually what will this do
does that do is just yeah that's right
that does the right thing yeah well just
if you just operate a map of F that it
also so it depends on that thing
returning the same length of thing
exactly exactly that is correct yeah all
right okay it's not it turns out that
that the generalizations we're talking
about aren't really related to this
which okay it's all right fine okay all
right let's go on with these sure so
adding more legs is like metrid that's
certainly true but if those legs are out
put legs and it's excreting to separate
arrays then there's no way to do that
with any function we have now you can
kind of fake it by doing a transpose
yeah just explain to me independent of
neuron that's what is the function you
want just operating on lists and things
you
it is a function that that takes level
specs for each of its separate arguments
that's to cut to the chase
well what arguments does it have it's
kind of like map thread in that it has a
runtime defined number of arguments so
Maps I'm at let's remind ourselves what
map thread does so if we say ABCD right
map third is going to do that right it's
going to be the transpose of that with F
on those things okay so now what is the
thing you want I want to point out that
if you copy pit could you just copy that
line down nope if you place the CD that
list with just C on its own single a
little fail it's gonna fail but in a
sense I shouldn't fail because the
thread wouldn't fail yes
thread would copy thread would judgment
it would broad effectively broadcast
that C into c comma C but it's not just
that it's that if you had a matrix in
the first argument if that if there if 8
I mean there's a certain argument that
this should work and auto duplicate that
second argument the second element sure
I think that's the less compelling
generalization because it's not even
that's not general enough okay um my
claim is that mr. Bogg that the second
dog and of maps where it takes this list
of things write up a list of these these
are field sources if there are things of
different rank it's not very well
defined what it means to walk over those
things at different levels so find a
matrix of the first I was a matrix and
the second guy was a vector now I would
want yeah I would want to F to see
duplicates of the vector elements as
long as the dimension prefixes match
right well so what you're saying is that
you want a map thread where where the
third argument has more structure than
just giving you a level spec because the
level spec would give you so for example
if I say array a let's say two to two
here it'll make that array now if I do a
map thread of that um on to that of that
so that's the first level map thread
right actually let let's do this um to
make it clearer what's going on um what
am i doing what's what did I do wrong
here oh because it's multi-argument eek
yeah I think I think you want to
separate arrays that are different ranks
and things hold on so let's first of all
just do this okay that's what that did
okay so now let me understand what the
thing does at level two okay
okay does that make sense to you
so level two each thing is just getting
I mean if we don't find this easy to
reason about because you've got one
array but really map thread you want to
think of those different arguments as
different arrays that you zipping over
all right okay okay let's do that let's
do that let's do that okay so then what
what you're saying is let's take this
let's take the a array is this and let's
say the B array is the same thing um but
just to choose if you want to do that
okay I was thinking let's do let's go
even deeper okay um okay so now here
you're saying a Arabia array mm-hm okay
and now if I can't make head or tail of
of this feels too deep and why have you
got it framed and they're mapping a
friend that seems very complicated well
because I was putting I was putting the
whole thing in an outer frame because
each framed here is going to show you
what that that's like a function that
outer framed is the function and those
are its two arguments okay so here okay
so this is
the next level down for each of those
two so this one the arguments here so
what you're saying is well you would
like this to do right so so that's an
those are arguments which are the same
there
they didn't dig all the way down on the
A's I'm sorry they didn't they dug all
the way down well almost all the way
down on the A's but they didn't dig all
the way down on the B's they've got two
more levels to go on the B's yes okay so
now explain what you want I'm sorry this
is a very minor point but I'd like to
report if Sushma could you see the icon
is not there yeah um can you report that
please um okay so tally what are you
proposing you want something which can
like can I go with an extremely simple
example which you don't need to generate
any A's or B's hold on I need to save
this summer hold on just a second I know
you
okay go ahead
what is it so if it's map thread of F
and then the a you can use a and B might
just help but the a was going to be for
the vector 1 2 3 and the B is going to
be the matrix 1 2 3 comma 4 5 6
actually I apologize 1 2 comma 3 4 comma
5 6 has to be the same length
okay fast
well the good news is the silly bug be
off by one bug or whatever it was in the
and selecting has now been fixed so that
was easier to type okay
like I get okay so what we would like to
have is a deeper if you put level two
here it wouldn't work
first of all does Maps red it doesn't
limit it to level two I've never
actually used that third argument it
back thread or is not level it can come
in a level you want I'm pretty sure this
one for example could go to level three
I think it means at level three that
means at level three exactly okay so so
just yeah go ahead just to clarify so if
we did comma two in my example it would
have well yeah but what I would want is
it just to say okay but it'll replicate
the first level the first argument first
which replicates to the depth that the
maximum depth I asked for well in this
case the depth that I asked for
right yeah that's feature number one is
just this replication thing okay but
feature number two would be that you can
actually um you can be very specific
about how much replication you want so
for example almost the opposite case of
this is where we have one two three is
the first of the first input and the
second input is just nine for example
just a scalar no and I want to rep
that mine up for that one two three
there look basically what you want to do
is you want to say what you want to say
given a level spec here you want
everything I mean one thing to do would
be to say given that level spec you want
everything to either be at that level or
to be replicated so that it can be at
that level it's not as simple as that
and the reason is that let's say that I
had nine nine nine right that might
actually be I want that to be replicated
even though it's already a vector of the
right size so I want to know what you
want to treat it as a yeah so okay this
is a very meaningful way of doing that
which is just level zero so I'm treating
if I'm gonna map the F over the first
thing the one two three at level one
that's just what ordinary map times
and then I want some the second argument
I want to be mapping over at level zero
which is another way of saying I'm not
mapping over it at all it's just being
repeated
so in a sense what you want to do is you
want to decorate the level specification
by saying you have a target level I mean
what you're going to do is is something
where you've got something like a list
of levels for every element of the map
thread a list of target levels for every
element to the map thread
but what you want is a list of which
contains both the
whole thing has a certain level that it
wants like it's going to be a level 2
map thread because that number there
determines the shape of the output right
so I'm gonna claim that actually what it
needs is a fourth argument
I'm going to claim this number defines
the desired output shape
know what I'm saying I'm I'm not a
hundred percent sure but I'm fairly sure
that that number is actually the maximum
of all the levels that you specify so
know when I sleep yeah in a scheme I'm
saying what level to map the F over each
of the arguments then whatever the max
of that those those levels is that is
effectively the dimension of the output
sort of definition I'm saying I'm saying
that you can say that but I'm saying a
different way to slice this is to say
that number defines the dimension of the
output
okay okay so
and in what sense does it define the
dimension of the output the answer is
the outermost list has always been
removed because the outermost list is
put innermost because that's the thing
because the F is threading over those
over those things right so the outermost
list is gone so the question is then
what is the depth of the final result
right so for example this one here
percent twenty I claim as obviously of
depth oh shoot well I mean it's list
step that I mean its dimensions right so
the depth of the the length of the
dimension so I claim here
I claim he says that the dimensions of
this will be a thing of length three and
I'm right okay this would be a thing of
length and if I were to say for example
here right comma four that will be a
thing of dimensions of whether
dimensions will
well whatever so it didn't make it there
so it couldn't do that because wasn't
deep enough right but okay
I'm claiming that the depth of the
output tensor is determined by that end
thing and the only question then is do
you the only ambiguity is if you're if
you say I require it to be of that depth
then you have to replicate in certain
cases but the only thing you might want
to do is to treat something as a you
know as a less of a tensor than you
thought it was more of a constant and
therefore you might want to replicate at
a higher you might want to start
replication even though you couldn't
principal burrow into the thing right
correct okay so I claim that we could
change map thread to actually auto
replicate is that desirable I don't know
I don't know maybe it's better to just
general narrow in this case but but so
that the point is that for every one of
these things you could be specifially
there is no ambiguity is that no no
there is for every one of the elements
of this list right you have to say what
its effective depth is right another
thing beyond that effect of depth is a
replication needs to replicate get what
I'm saying I think you're correct but I
think that's in the end gonna be the
opposite way that you'll want to specify
it in practice you're not going to want
to specify what its effective depth is
you're gonna want to specify it at what
level you're gonna you wish to walk over
it so I'll give an example if you want
to treat something as constant you don't
wanna have to like calculate how deep it
happens to be and then compensate
against the depth you mapping to figure
out what affected all right right right
so you want to say what the effective
depth
okay so the parameters the the the you
know if it was the fourth org gives the
effective depth to assume for each
element
okay
yeah
right so okay so what we're saying is
that we can we do some examples that'd
be very helpful
yes yes yes but what I'm suggesting is
that the way we think about it is map
thread is okay so roughly what this
would be is let's say you know e 1 e 2 e
3 whatever they are okay then this is D
D is the
okay Saudi gives the
list depth so to speak of the resulting
tensor
okay and so by default okay and then
this here gives um let's call them well
we can just call them d1 d2 d3 here
okay so d1 di are the effective lists
depths to assume for the e I right okay
so to be specific here um what what I'm
saying is the effective list step that
could be 0 in which case it's just pure
application right so for example if I
said map thread so in your example here
this would be um I have a very specific
claim that I'm gonna make right away and
I might turn out to be wrong which is D
equals max of the D I always it has to
be no I don't think you're correct
because I think you could have a let me
give you an example
okay so here
okay women are the effective less steps
to assume for the EEI okay so normally
these the default values here will be 1
0 right that's what that's what those
are that's what they are on their faces
so to speak but if I were to say 0 0
here then the result that I would get
would be um the list I should I don't
want a 2 there well maybe if I do get it
if I do put it too
actually I would the one would be the
max no 2 is that that's right there
because that means you're treating them
as constant but then there's no levels
to map over anymore
like you're treating them as scalars but
then you don't have any way to work why
am I not just getting f of 1 2 3 , 9 I'm
it's not very exciting but why don't I
get that to the other two doesn't make
any sense I agree anyone the value for
that argument makes sense and it's the
max of all the other things you've
written because the result that this
thing produces it got the shape of the
result by mapping over at least one of
those inputs to a certain depth that's
yes deepest one that tells you the shape
of the fine well all right
our is the label of the like extreme are
concluding the same thing that you're
concluding only and an insect analogy
it's that the shape of X of its excreta
comes from its walking right and the
faster does it fastest it walks
I think this insect is going to make it
I think okay so I I agree with you I
think and people on the live stream are
making the same point then I think the
correct answer here is something where
there is where it looks like this where
for each of the ISA by there's a depth
specified yeah I think so and the
alternative the only question is in the
current situation where there's a single
D currently where erroring out in the
case where you know that single D would
be equivalent to the the the DDD case
presumably
that right
I think it is and that will what that
requires so specifically there's a
property we require for this thing to be
well defined which is that if you were
to take the dimensions of the EIS in the
sequence and then for each one take the
DI first of those dimensions one of
those prefixes have to match so first D
what D 1 dimensions of e 1 have to match
the first D 2 dimensions of e 2 etc
yeah I think I agree and then everything
replicates beyond that so it doesn't
matter so the dimensions well I'm not
showing but that's let's see we are
various comments on the livestream here
um
okay so we have let's just take a look
care um
a very complicated case here sent
through by what is this this is
the claim is that that will be what was
going on um but this is now
so do we believe this um
that's interesting suggestion um
suggestion isn't an option broadcast
arrow automatic I think broadcast is a
it's a little bit of a of a of a complex
analogy but but that's I think there's a
there's a very interesting meeting we
should and need to have about
broadcasting at some point I even have
an alternative name which is replicate
which i think is like more direct and
evocative even though everyone calls it
broadcasting in other languages what do
you mean what-what-what's but but yes
there is a story about about you know
there's a whole missing piece for a lot
of what's going on to do with
broadcasting of what do you what do you
mean I mean it's very difficult not
impossible to to do program broadcasting
on arrays in our language what do you
mean well I don't even know what that
means
so broadcasting is when you introduce
dimensions in the middle of of an array
and you will will copy the sub tenses up
to fill in that dimension that you've
introduced right
we've done a bunch of things with
flatten and array flatten and so on the
right to that okay what are you
referring to well well let's not go
through this right now I mean for
example array flatten has a whole bunch
of capabilities and also the the
multiple arguments are flattened do a
bunch of things like this that perhaps
there's some missing documentation
related to this because I not heard the
term broadcast referring to that
particular operation on arrays so that's
a Sushma that's something for you to
note down and maybe we can pick this up
in some I'll be meeting and I tally and
we'll talk about whatever this is okay
yeah yeah that's what I'd like to do and
maybe not it's a bit of a rabbit hole so
let's think this is not but now right
now yeah um okay so somebody is
commenting that thread of F of a B okay
what is this identity really
and if F doesn't evaluate them that can
sometimes be true no I don't think but
that's not generally true I'm sorry okay
Sandra our live stream is saying for the
dimensions the following should hold he
says and see his crime here
you
the two part is confusing me well that's
a that's a flattened at level that's in
fact something related to what you were
just talking about
that's a flattened at level two okay but
the dimensions of all those things
that's already a matrix so why does flat
thing at level two do anything to it
I think we'd have to try this um okay
but in a case let's let's zoom out for a
minute
so so far as we can tell
okay so the claim here is that we can
simply specify the D 1 the the D sub I
here and the only question that we don't
know the answer to is this identity here
is this identity correct or is it
something more complicated no no no I'm
very confident that that is correct but
this hum wrecked yep okay walk me
through what the D sub I mean again what
is the description of the D sub I the D
sub I I mean I'm in a district revert to
the language that that I use internally
in my brain to think about this which is
you you will you're mapping a function
across these different arguments
simultaneously but at different levels
for the different arguments those DS
have I are the different levels how deep
you go into each of those those ease to
accomplish the mapping
and it's but very when when you have to
go deeper I mean the max of the D sub I
you anything shorter than that gets lie
right ultimately the testes produce is
of size max of the D Sub I exactly so it
is the the deepest thing that the
deepest D so it specifically this it
kind of
okay so wouldn't it does um does the
mapping to level di in E I replicating
AI if necessary to
it's actually replicating the other eyes
so if one of the the ears is deeper than
the others and new mapping over a deeper
than that
okay okay replicating any e eye
no no no that's not right because this
di specifies replicating the e I if the
final if the max okay okay so this
produces a tensor of depth max of the D
eyes
right correct at least and good is the F
codes let's do whatever crazy thing it
does right so yeah um okay so it does
the mapping to level d sub I um
okay
replicating
if
you
replicating whatever it finds at that
level if
it needs to in order to get a final
tensor of depth max di it's horribly
said but I think that's correct
statement yes through cases because it
could be the case that this is the D sub
I is shallower than the actual element e
sub I in which case what it's doing is
its treating the deeper depths of e sub
I as a scaler effectively right or yep
the D sub I could be defining you know
how deep you go in that e sub i yes but
and here's a crucial point that I I was
worried you were you getting wrong which
is that that di cannot be deeper cannot
be higher than the depth of the
corresponding e sub I that's not where
their application I agree I agree I
agree
hmm it must be the case that for each I
D sub I is less than or equal to e sub I
right depth don't be somebody oh the
depth of Issa by the list depth of Issa
by array depth I think is the actual
formula that's right and so maybe a
better way to just to talk about the
broadcasting something like oh all ye I
for which di is less than the max get
replicated to effectively be of the max
depth no that's not right that's not
right
no it's not right no it's not right
because oli I the whole point is you're
assuming a a fake depth di for the e I
right the depth D I could be not the
full depth of the e I right you're
assuming that luck that the it could be
the case that the top the the lower
layers okay consider the following okay
we have something which has the form you
know one two you know five six okay we
can either treat that as something which
is to be mapped over at level 1 or at
level two right
so the D sub I says so in this one if I
say if the D sub I is 1 then what will
end up happening is it will treat 1 2 as
a lump as a scalar lump right agree by
is 2 then it will dig down into those
things assuming I agree
assuming that the total max di is big
enough that that digging is what it is
calling for yes
no I I'm not talking about that you can
release my point is not really about one
guy in isolation its
if you had a second thing which was like
nine that was a 1 and E 2 is like 9 okay
right and therefore necessarily had a
corresponding depth of 0 that's the only
depth you allowed to use for 9
then so your point is that the the DI in
that case is kind of redundant
for the nine for the element that is
nine no it's not my point but but that's
true in fact because the only value the
DI could have there is zero yes that is
true but the point at the point I was
trying to make is that the fact that the
nine gets replicated what we've got to
communicate in the usage message of this
putative extension of map thread is how
exactly that nine gets replicated and
under wonder what conditions it gets
replicated and what I'm what I'm trying
to find is the right language for you
know the depth is zero that depth zero
is less than the depth of the other
arguments which might be one or two or
something and that tells you how many
ranks get replicated of that line
sure so in this case it if it was the
nine compared to this and this was and
it was going to depth to then you'd be
be doing you know then effectively the
nine if this was a depth to thing then
what effectively would happen is that
nine would effectively be this yeah
exactly
replica well the amount of replication
is basically you know it's is array of
the thing and then a list of length
young dimensions of length max and ODI
I think it's max di- deep it's max di-
particular di right no I don't think so
oh yeah yeah for this case I'm sorry yes
you're right I was talking about this
case when it's a scaler
yes it's the length list of length max
di - probably plus 1 I think - di yeah
and that's effectively that's this
that's the deficit of rank that you
brought that you're filling and that's
really well that's right that's all it
is
yes that's all it is right Phil Phil Zim
whatever rank a particular element
doesn't have so to speak exactly okay I
can't persist I have to tell you what at
least part of the story for there for
what my proposal is for broadcasting
more generally in the language and that
is it it's a rapper called replicated
you'll see it you'll see why it made
sense
it's a rapper called replicated yes and
what it does is it replicated of argh
the thing that you want to replicate ,
and then how much rank to add so like a
deficit - and what it means is if you're
doing like that so you're doing total or
let's see adding a vector to a matrix as
I'm sure you've liked know from many
decades with the language if that's the
wrong way around
tally that's clever right so what you
can say if you say the list six seven
plus replicated
five comma one that's actually that case
works already with NIST ability right
well yes but but but there plenty of
cases like that but don't work right so
like maybe a matrix with some two
vectors in it and the matrix has got
three of those two vectors in it okay
and then you want to add another 2
vector list ability it does do
replication going wrong the problem with
this is that I mean what really you'd
want to do here is just say replicated
of six seven and have that do Auto you
know have the auto list ability so to
speak figure out what the rank has to be
and its current that can be perfect and
that the rules further very well-defined
which is the the thing that they're
placated appears as an argument of in
this case plus it has a bunch of other
arguments they have dimensions just look
at them and see what the replicated
argument is missing and fill it in fill
in those dimensions by replication yeah
I understand this is a good idea this is
a very interesting idea surprising we
didn't think of this in the last 30
years well done
the okay I should have a proper
treatment of it's another time perhaps
yes okay for the aisle the agenda um
okay now Seth on the live stream is
talking about what happens in a
particular map thread let me just copy
that out um so this map thread
hmm what does happen in that map thread
Charlie I don't know if you use the
default we are the default that argument
is one that'll always fail
the default third argument was zero it
would treat these as scalars now the
default con yeah
you can't remember that's actually just
composed that just like what's a client
actually is what it is yes it's opposed
right yeah okay but so the climbers this
can never work and do we ever want this
to me nothing
yes that there's a possible thing we
could have this mean the thing we could
have this mean yes there is a set no no
no this is incorrect
okay the following thing should work
okay I claim this should work okay and
what that will do is it should return F
of 1 comma 4 5
, you know f of 2 comma 4 5 etc right
now notice that there's an identity here
because this is the same as saying loops
that's the same as if we wanted to if
I'm if I'm going replication crazy I
could say in here replicated for 5
yes it is level one yeah that's true
okay all right well I think we've got a
winner here in terms of map threat and I
really love this replicated idea um
I really love that idea I mean that will
solve a whole bunch of weird problems
with the stability it's kind of the it's
the it's a sort of it it's a way of
controlling the stability and
interesting way of controlling the
stability okay all right so let's go
back and look at the original neural net
case and and what are we gonna do with
map third are we able to put these new
arguments in do you think that's
possible
I mean it's C so it's that's a Gordian
or two before the freeze day yeah I
don't think that's realistic one
question is does this suggest that we
should have a net map thread operator
that behaves quite differently to
network operator I was imagining we
would just extend network operator um
thread I don't think this is a net map
operator thing I mean this is this seems
much more like a map thread because this
type of control
this type of multi-legged not wishing to
spider this up too much but you know
this sort of multi-legged behavior is
really not a map kind of thing
if that's what this operator is doing is
that what this operator is doing it is
yeah I mean there's some little details
that are quite unique to neural networks
like for example we we have to look at
the the internet so just you recall that
mean absolute loss layer if you just
copy that that constructor art and run
it here yes you'll see that it's it's a
two argumented it's got
so it's about two two inputs and one
output you have a broken old bulls just
use eleven three for nards it's no
different there okay all right okay yeah
so now what just expand that so you can
see all the the both inputs and the
opposite symptom so input and output
it's got an input a target and an
awkward the output is loss okay dad that
you have to any you know you want to map
over the input on the target
simultaneously so that's the sort of map
thread pipe situation yes but we have
this unique thing property that that the
inputs and the outputs are actually
named right they effectively always
associations yeah that's a different
extension to map thread that I think is
quite reasonable which is to make them
work on associations not just lists yes
but um we can right so that's it that's
effectively that particular thing is the
sub case of associations right which I
don't think map thread works on at all
right now it doesn't well we should
probably fix it I mean there's so what
you're saying is there's a K 1 e 1 here
K 2 e 2 right that doesn't seem
particularly problematic yeah and all
that would do is it would pass those
same sub associations to F prime engine
friend case one goes to hold on actually
hold on this is
right picture this isn't the right
picture what we which picture are you
talking about are you talking about this
picture here this is what you had before
is perfectly good okay
but then then what's past to F is
something of the form so let's imagine
these ones are you imagining that II one
is the list 1 2 for example and E 2 is
the list 3 4 for instance
okay so what's passed to F I don't think
is what you think it is I think what oh
yes it is I'm sorry I'm sorry so then
what's passed to F is f of k 1 arrow 1 K
2 arrow 3 right that seems very
reasonable to me but then what this is
going to return ok so although this is
effectively a transpose where it's
taking that inner list and it's you know
extracting the inner list as the
outermost wrapper here and this is going
to end up with that arrow to for correct
sure yeah I think it's perfectly
reasonable for that to work I mean is it
the case if I just take if I would take
yeah I mean because this is analogous to
saying F mapped over this right does
that
so I believe this is kind of an
analogous thing well try try try thread
of f of an association that would I
think make it a slam-dunk argument I
don't know if that works but it could
that could work I think yeah I mean
doing well let's just think what that
would do so what the thread would do in
that case is the same thing that we're
proposing the map thread is doing here
right I mean other words anymore what
sir I don't know yeah yeah and if you
know I know if I do this if I just say 1
2 3 4 then that will thread like that
right so the correct thing for this to
do is exactly what we're proposing map
thread to do where that the correct
thing then is on the Association is for
this thing to come out as um essentially
exactly this not a bit different about
it is that there's a missing list so
that thread works that final thread with
the 1 2 3 4 F of 1 2 3 4 but this is the
wrong case this is the wrong case this
is the wrong case that the correct case
for this thread the correct thing for
this to do if you thread this would be
to give k1 arrow um
what is the right thing it's that
okay let's look at this case here so if
I say
humph
what is the right thing so that the
thread of this um
the things that thread fundamentally
wants to match different arguments of
the F but with the Association you've
only got one argument which is the
Association yeah so in fact this is the
wrong analogy that what we should be
looking at is yeah this is what we
should be looking at as K goes to 1 K 2
goes to 3 let's say and then second
argument here which is this thing goes
to 2 that thing goes to 4
all right that's the correct analogy
that is on this and then and then in
fact that thread which undoubted us work
right now should be k1 yes this is
correct k1 goes to F of 1/2 k2 goes to F
of 3 for 3 cool
yes that's true ok the truth of it that
I hope we actually agree and I think we
should fix that
that doesn't honestly have much to do
with the map thread though
but is the same su I mean it's it's both
of these things could be fixed you know
it's in the same family of association
related straight initials now yes
okay so Sushma please an ILD meeting you
know covering but no that would take
okay just just this one for the
association's then this is a simpler
thing
okay generalizing map thread putting in
these associations
address the replicated idea
oh so the association one should be
sooner than later um well it's not gonna
make it for twelve yes um I mean this is
so that would be look put all three of
them together but replicate third
element in that list okay meanwhile on
our live stream various questions and
comments here was a question about the
end video RTX 2009 oh nothing about that
yes
and so basically eleven point three
doesn't work for it's because it's using
an older version of CUDA and the version
of CUDA that supports this new GPU was
only released about ten days ago so okay
those version 12 full version twelve
supported yep yes amazing even though it
was only released ten days ago yeah we
were rebuilding in mixed nuts like in
the next few days with that okay it's
that part of the did did somebody else
add that to a max net or do we have to
do that what happens like an extant
builds crack against could attend so
there was nothing for us to do okay good
okay so that's the answer to that
question um is it going to have some
spectacular i I don't I I'm not
following all the all the serial numbers
of all these different devices so is
that something particularly spectacular
then I
is that even consumer cards are getting
tentacles so we're hoping to leverage
tentacles 4:12 previously liked or
neither very expensive professional GPUs
had them I see I see
oh that's about as exciting does that
mean my my next-generation laptop is
gonna I have no idea what GPU like my
laptop has in it what what what is what
is in max these days they're all AMD's
exactly that mean nothing works and in
terms of GPU extensions there's the
magnet support the yeah go ahead yes
okay so basically an excellent doesn't
support open CL or whatever the thing is
for AMD AMD is working on a hook for an
X nuts
so there's plans probably for next year
to have time to they should they should
hop on it otherwise they're gonna get
left behind
um okay various comments on our live
stream somebody is commenting that Karl
Angus commenting can't you use threading
layer of net map operator for that but
I'm not sure what the that is anymore
um that's a that's a kind of bit of a
Frankenstein yin one stirred feels like
yeah threading layer the argument it's
reading layers is scalar function
fundamentally I don't think it makes
sense to give it an it from yeah and
look the other thing I would say is that
net function will introduce a different
way of creating knits that will make
some of these things somewhat obsolete
so like you wouldn't even use net map
operator you just use the map thread
directly right by the way of SW SH on
our live stream is claiming this
identity there's
yes okay um okay so so back to a net map
operator or or net map thread operator
yeah can we go through the proposed
design because I think yes I think it's
just I think it's you'll just agree and
learn but then document it um okay so
the difference with the map thread that
you ready I really like that by the way
I hadn't thought of extending map thread
I thought this would require a new
function but that is obviously the right
way to do it to extend map thread okay
so but back to what you are proposing
here you're proposing changes to the net
map operator and we could make a new
operator knit knit maps rate operator
factors view proposing for net map
operator the second argument that takes
the levels and their input levels just
like what have you been discussing yes
the only difference is they are
identified with particular string inputs
so particular named input ports rather
than positional advices like this yes
can they be an association or is there
not no uniqueness of the left-hand sides
it could be an association sure
okay fine but but see you're proposing
here that this is this seems harmless
honestly I don't think this is
ultimately the way that this stuff will
be done because I think you know once we
have net function and more of this kind
of higher level representation I suspect
we'll be able to do that instead but
this seems like a perfectly reasonable
way to annotate net map operator example
he doesn't have a second argument right
now
exactly you know okay and the behavior
of these things will be the same as the
d-sub eyes of map thread that we've been
proposing correct it will be exactly the
same okay
okay single single integer this means
use that integer for all the different
inputs fine with me
oh wait a minute is that the same
behavior as the map thread proposal yes
it is okay all right fine with me okay
single string means that one is one and
the rest of zeros all right I it's
harmless I think okay okay cool
so fold operator is the tricky case okay
it's it's tricky because the main
generalization is again now that week is
going to support multiple inputs not
just sort of hard-coded one input in one
state you need to say how the states
connect to each other so are you two you
kind of want a quick refresher on enfold
operator well I thought I understood it
I mean as a as a fault but when you say
the states connect that that's in order
to feed in a fold you obviously have to
feed the thing onto the next stage in
the fold is that what you're talking
about yes so the knits that internet
will produce two outputs or more one of
them you save to be just part of the
final list the other is the state that
is passed forward to one of the inputs
evaluated but that's um that that's fold
beardless I mean isn't that fold pair
yep
no we know this we just didn't call it
an n-fold pair operator because it was
sort of needlessly you know needlessly
comfortable I mean it's needlessly
complicated I mean and fold pair is a
fairly complicated idea but if this is
in fact doing a fold pair and now that's
coming out so anyway what are you
proposing here you're proposing
this is
that's the fold operator but it's
actually a fold pair operator and and
the the complexity that is the extra
feature we adding is to say which
outputs get feedback into which impact
I could I get I mean in principle fold
pair could have a thing like this as
well hmm I'd how many arguments does it
have now I seem to remember being pretty
rich um no well it has quite a few it
has okay so what are those arguments
there so the success of X sub I obtained
by applying aft pairs of the form y sub
I a sub I right word each step it emits
an ax and returns the Y sub I that will
be fed on
okay so what you're doing here is you're
saying which port from which port the
thing that will be fed on comes is that
right so you're effectively saying
instead of what we're here F has to
return actually it's sort of an
interesting generalization because for
both fold pair list and for subset map
we're dealing with
which by the way reminds me Sushma can
we make sure that fall palest refers to
subset map and vice versa um the
so okay hold on let's sum so what I'm
saying is right now which thing comes
out as the next y sub I
you know so f get was I'm saying F is
returning X sub I y sub I right and the
emitted thing is being extracted as the
first element of that and the fed on
thing is is the second element but
that's pretty arbitrary
in principle there could be another
argument or some structure which is what
you're proposing here that determines
which of the things that F returns which
thing is return you know which thing is
return this value on which thing is fed
on yes and and it's really multiple
things could be could be fed back so
that pair could become at the general
tupple that's actually Ellis TMS do that
Ellis terms have two separate states
that are maintained separately now in
the language that doesn't much matter
because you can always keep the separate
states as a Yost and if alerted with but
like in the world of these frameworks
you really you don't have that notion of
like compound objects it's just tensors
and I wish we did have the notion of
those compound objects but it's it's too
late to end perhaps we should consider
that that's a separate discussion
mmm right okay so okay so for this
purpose here what are we saying the so
what you're proposing is a thing that
specifies what can be fed on
which one of these as that is I'm sorry
which one is the but what you're saying
is the F returns this and then the
question is where do those which pieces
get returned and where do they get
plugged in that's what you're basically
saying here yeah I think we're just
talking about which kid which get
plugged in I don't think we double-check
could you bring up Ned fold operator sir
just everyone can see no embarrassing to
admit but I I'm I need to be oh yes
there's only one output in that cool
computer si effectively using net of
input error si state arrow that mm-hmm
okay so what are you proposing here so
what I'm proposing is that's that list
of rules tells you which output gets fed
back to which input in the next step
what do you mean by which input I mean M
1 means what because here I'm seeing the
input is an association
yes so well it has one mean does one
mean an association with key element
with key one so that is Matt fitting so
that's an awkwardness maybe let's just
strike art option one is clearly stupid
because it's confusing it's joining the
mapping with state recurrences okay fine
idea okay okay so what what does what
does this mean here
that's saying expect them the the nets
to have an output called state and feed
that output called state back into the
input called state a different input
okay look at what if this mean that was
meant to be the level at which you got a
map over because not only are you doing
some feeding back but you are so
separately mapping over an input
sequence remember the A's if you go back
to fold pay list it was the lister
always that were coming from the input
list yes so if in theory can map level
two so you can map the pixels of an
image for example and you maintaining
states from open so that means a
completely different thing I mean the
state arrow State thing is a completely
different type of thing that's the
that's kind of the the knitting together
of the things inside the fold and this
has to do with a this has to do with how
you iterate how the fold I don't even
understand how that can work with fold
is a very threaded linear thing it
doesn't fold doesn't get to go over a
two-dimensional array it's quite easily
can though how what order
the the same order as map does so in an
image for example you know top to bottom
left to right so so as a courtesy then
what you're doing is you're mapping that
your your first flattening and then
folding is that correct I don't think it
is correct no so the states can be
passed on different levels
that's actually an extension that I
mentioned at the bottom of this so
that's the same thing as the map thread
thing of of the as if scaler at a
certain level I think so I'm not sure
but like can you gue sorry I should have
put an image of this in the notebook
could you just google for grid Ellis TM
it'll you'll see some nice pictures I'm
sure all right after I have to get going
soon unfortunately um and we have a
request
okay I really have to go in a moment but
let's some you know what I realized now
and maybe you'll forgive me because I
think it is the first section we nailed
I realize now that this net fault
operator proposal needs a little bit of
work it's also the one I haven't
implemented yet so it's it's I wouldn't
stop me if in the slightest bit so the
basic idea is thanks for about that it
is it is somewhat because they're also
two separate states to each self but um
the basic it is that as you mapping you
you obtaining a state from the pixel to
your left and from the pixel above you
yes right
well that's that's otherwise known as a
block map right that's what block map
does know if there's no there's no
dependency between there's a running
state that connects all the tiles all
the little applications of F I see I see
I see I see I see so this is essentially
a block fold yeah it's a two-dimensional
exactly it's a two-dimensional fault
and I think it's hot because it has to
it has to depend on certain previous
things I think yes it does have to
depend on the thing above it and the
things below what
fun about all of this is that you know
all of this list manipulation you know I
I thought we'd figured out every
conceivable you know iteration but it is
interesting that the neural net world
introduces yet more kind of ten serology
um okay so that's for the next time okay
just a quick thing for a live stream
folk they really want to see net
function what can we show them about net
function the net function set they will
not ship for twelve is twelve point one
oh but a very high priority but um I
will mention one this show up what show
one thing on the screen just for people
to see something about what net function
is sure I can share okay alright super
quick here go your leg let me make sure
that I have my notebooks that I want to
share on screen okay so so the first
place that the net function like
functionality will show up and I
actually thought we were gonna ship this
for twelve because it's quite limited in
scope but it will be the way that you
define losses so when you have a net
there's the object that you want to use
at the end of training right the thing
that's that sort of does that in hand
but that's often quite different from
how the net is trained and we have very
limited amount of functional or
functionality currently to elaborate
that evaluation net so that it's able to
be trained and there's a certain amount
of automatic magic that happens at the
still picture you'll remember but we
want to overhaul is quite considerably
so that you can much more flexibly kind
of construct the training environment
for the net weights that are gonna be
taught and this is what you see here is
a sort of a prototype of what that'll
look like and what it'll look like is
you've got access to the training data
so these are keys from the training data
I got it and you've also got access to
the net and then you just write what the
thing is that you're trying to minimize
and this is will be symbolically
evaluated it won't actually see training
data in this
we'll we'll evaluate this to construct a
bigger net that will be the training
environment but then what you get back
at the end of training is just the net
don't you feel a word in that function
anywhere here what exactly it's not here
because this is a limited enough slice
of functionality that it looks like
ordinary function application and we can
move but ultimately net function is
going to have to use the compiler and
everything yes that true um I think the
compiler stuff will more be used for for
custom layers than for net function well
I haven't yet understood net function
then okay so yeah this unlocks ligand
training and all kinds of things I'm
sorry how does it unlock gam training
the story is still a little complicated
there I'm not sure I have 100% figured
it out but that one of the things that
will make it easy to do is you'll define
several pieces of your net and then you
can kind of a symbol in the lost
function so there's a generator and
disorder mayor trusting that's cool yeah
that's really cool um that is very
interesting that I had not understood
how the gann mechanism was going to fit
in um
you
hmm this comes so one of the things one
of the reasons that net function becomes
such is actually such a big project is
that it requires us to port a lot of
kind of of the sort of fed like
innovations I guess you could call them
from the neural net side of things into
the language itself so a good example
would be what we're doing with map
thread we would need that to be there so
that you can express those kinds of nets
have a pure annika code so brother yeah
and there's quite a number of those
things we will still need to you know of
course I will present what those designs
look like I'm not gonna assume that you
know we can just put things in directly
we will need to find a way to to map
that functionality over that's one of
the reasons it's tough fair enough
Karl lagging on our live stream is
complaining about having to do too much
work to create loss functions it will be
interesting I encourage you just send us
some examples of loss functions and what
you've had to do because then we can
make sure that in the future version all
that stuff is unscrambled all right I
need to go um great
alright so there's some documentation
work and there's one more iteration here
with this net fold thing that are going
to be needed right right um those who
are interested in live streaming my gosh
we're going to be doing another live
stream probably in about 45 minutes 30
minutes about some web execute
functionality then something about
unsupervised learning and then something
about geometric computing and then see
this is what happens near the end of the
version there's a there's a um this is
just a whole vast long list and then one
about natural language processing after
that so exciting stuff um thanks all see
you later
Thanks